[Applause]
here he is the man Vince Carter for
Carter
the heavy favorite to win it contests
performance the league has ever seen
took it through the highest level the
slam dunk contest has ever been before
on their feet like gods that hit the
game-winning shot the NBA Finals when
this was happening and the most
anticipated event of all-star Saturday
the nba.com slam dunk contest are you
feeling any pressure at all everybody's
saying Vince is gonna win I don't feel
any pressure buts gonna go out there
have fun and hopefully I can get a win
here is the man that this crowd wants to
see and we're gonna see what Vince
Carter can really do it if he does this
like I said
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just exploded
I was just ridiculous and he's my
greatest doctor if not be braised on
football town
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with the tribute to Vince Carter water
with a spectacular show my favorite
Duncan's of all time it's only about the
baby
[Music]